Moonie clash of clans the horse's name
was Friday
what horse breath hey guys back at it
again
reading and responding to your YouTube
comments what songs are on your workout
playlist and - how often do you have a
cheat day where you eat whatever I love
EDM I grew up on EDM listening to Tiesto
back in a day so anything that has a
high rhythm fast pace I'm one of those
people that listens to just about
anything if it sounds good
I know that's kind of a cop out of an
answer but it's true cheat day how often
do I have a cheat day I tend to use the
idea that you should constantly be
eating healthy and then occasionally
indulge in sweets and cheats and all
that so I don't have like a schedule
where okay Sunday's my cheat day I'm
surprised that you said you box are you
concerned about CTE great question
traumatic encephalopathy is a real issue
you see what's going on in the NFL a lot
of now that being said do we have a
perfect understanding of CTE by any
means the answer is really no I've been
to sports medicine conferences where
pathologists have talked about the
damage that we label CTE on autopsies
being prevalent in those who have never
played contact sports but we obviously
know that hitting your head getting
concussions over and over again is not
healthy I do something known as body
sparring which is you have a helmet on
but you're not going for the other
person's face so you're only hitting
each other's bodies yes you can't get
hurt but you're not gonna be hitting
each other's heads so you don't need to
worry about CTE hey Doc what is a nude
person on strike wear mmm what is a nude
person on strike wear I don't know it is
a trick question what is this nude
person on strike where yangzhou Lin
please explain to me what does a nude
person on strike wear can you make a
video on how to get rid of water
retention
thanks love you in your videos Thank You
Julia boom I appreciate it I think that
very commonly people will over eat salty
foods without even knowing it they'll
say I don't even add salt to my food so
how can I be over consuming salt and in
reality what happens is people eat very
salty foods like Chinese food is very
salty Chipotle salt it's very salty when
you eat you know three four five meals
that are high in salt you're gonna have
more salt and your body's gonna have
more water retention if you're having
severe water retention you should go get
a check-up with your doctor and figure
out why it is that you're retaining
water
stay active sleep seven to nine hours a
week a day imagine if you slept seven
tonight hours a week you a vampire seven
to nine hours a night and eat healthy
not too much sodium doesn't mean don't
eat sodium but not too much yoga by DD
do you do yoga I have done yoga I want
to do more yoga I've done Bikram yoga
but I want to try vinyasa and all those
other forms if you're in the New York
City area and you own a yoga studio I'm
down to come by and check it out
reptilian Overlord Jason Blaha could be
the best username I've ever read dr.
Mike how much protein is required to
build muscle in reality the RDA which is
recommended dietary allowance is
basically 50 grams of protein per day
that's what the percentages that you see
on Nutrition Facts represent if you're
trying to build muscle and you're
exercising very heavily people sometimes
think they're exercising very heavily
when they're really not so they try and
up their protein thinking that it's
gonna help them build build muscle more
readily I don't like to overdo it when
it comes to those things I've seen the
recommendation of one gram of protein
per kilogram in your body and I think
that's that's a fairly safe way of
increasing your protein intake from the
RDA if you're training to build more
muscle how many days a week do you go to
the gym dr. Mickey my name is not dr.
Mickey Clemente I go to the gym about
three four times a week lately I haven't
been weight training as much I've been
doing more cardio because I've been
wanting to play sports I've been playing
a lot of indoor soccer and playing
basketball which I still count that's
really good exercise you don't have to
always be weight training but research
has shown that a combination of cardio
and weight training is usually best for
our health so I'm gonna keep doing both
Michael BIST Rick do a video on grooming
your hair every where is it grooming
your hair everywhere
your body or grooming your hair
everywhere like doing it in a cab on the
couch in the bathroom I think I know
what you mean I will do a grooming
routine very soon I promise
you have my word what Internet resources
can I trust for medical information I
really love family doctor org I think it
gives a lot of broad health information
that is easy to understand it's written
in common English and doesn't have
complicated medical terms that may not
mean a lot to you if you're not in the
scientific field if you're a medical
student I would recommend using
up-to-date leave at doctor mic which
means hi in Russian I worry for you as
you appear to perfect Casper I promise
you I'm not perfect I have weaknesses I
mess up the difference between I think
myself and someone who's unhappy is that
I am generally more okay with failure
I'm generally more okay with feeling sad
because I think it's part of life
I view stress as my friend and I use
every failure as a learning opportunity
so I think that when you set those types
of goals for yourself you're generally a
happier person but by no means am i
perfect
I'm very messy when it comes to taking
care of my house and my organization
skills are but I'm learning I'm trying
to get better every day that's what
makes it fun so enjoy the ride Ryan
Peggy er why are some periods heavy and
some light are you qualified to answer
that do you have to be a different type
of doctor to do so no you don't have to
be a different type of doctor I'm a
family medicine physician so I do
gynecologic care I do
obstetric care I do pap smears just so
you're aware like the type of practice
that a family physician does women's
periods the menstrual cycle in general
varies first of all woman to woman and
it varies month to month based on a
multitude of factors diet exercise
stress levels hormonal changes sleep
changes even environment changes all of
those things play a role in deciding on
how regular your period is going to be
how heavy your periods going to be so
it's important that when you go see your
doctor and you say hey I
I've experienced the change in my
menstrual cycle you give all those
details to a doctor so then we can
figure out and piece together a possible
cause or multiple causes and then use
some testing and some physical exam
signs to rule them out candy pop love he
said vasovagal response and i heard it
ways of beagle response I'm just so
stupid
no you're not you're actually really
funny and that's one of your strengths
what is your opinion cosmetic plastic
surgery Lauren I know some people aren't
happy with the appearance that they're
born with and it's totally
understandable I'm not like totally
against it I think there are instances
where people get addicted to it and I
think that plastic surgeons could do a
better job of screening this out I'm not
saying they have to be diagnosed with
body dysmorphia disorder just some
people you can tell that they've gotten
too much plastic surgery and I think
that's when plastic surgeon should step
in and be honest and open with their
patients and think about their patients
health more than their health of their
wallet that's me being a little preachy
but if whatever procedure you want to
have is important to you and it's
causing the disfigurement or whatever
you're upset about is causing you
significant distress then you weigh the
harms of that distress versus the
possible harms of that surgery and the
benefits are removing those feelings and
you make a decision that's a
personalized one for yourself remember
plastic surgery is also pretty expensive
and not covered by insurance Thomas Tom
repetitive explain how zombie apocalypse
could happen Tom this is my worst
nightmare actually it's my second worst
nightmare my first worst nightmares
nuclear war which I have dreams about
all the time but the second worst
nightmare is a zombie apocalypse it can
happen like this there's a scientist
somewhere in Siberia I don't know why I
said Siberia that's kind of messed up
against Russian people considering I'm
Russian but so there's a scientist
working in a desolate place and he's
working with all these different viruses
that can mutate and we you don't have an
answer for that aren't able able to be
killed by traditional means like alcohol
sanitizers heat even and it basically
makes people into zombies like they're
not necessarily dead but it makes them
that they turn into cannibals and they
want to eat each other and go crazy
hope it doesn't happen
I can't happen I'm just say make it
happen Thomas Tom or really if we spend
enough time on social media we'll all
turn into zombies as always stay happy
and healthy
[Music]